[Musica]
[Applauso]
Buonasera a tutti e tutte
Caspita quanti siete e vi vedo male con
le luci e io questa sera spero di
parlarvi di qualcosa che che non tutti
conoscete bene vi parlo dell'urbex chi
di voi ne ha mai sentito parlare alzate
le mani
Caspita nessuno bene Molto interessante
vi divertirete e alle mie spalle ci sarà
tutta una serie di immagini che vi
accompagneranno e vi aiuteranno anche a
capire meglio il senso di questo
intervento sono immagini vedrete di
porsi abbandonati ma non solo e partiamo
tutti voi avete un'abitazione avete una
casa privata o in affitto
indipendentemente da questo e
probabilmente la vostra casa è piena di
oggetti che negli anni avete accumulato
oggetti d'affezione foto di famiglia
foto delle grigliate con gli amici
l'armadio della nonna tutta una serie di
vestiti appositamente scelte
appositamente Comprati
una chitarra o un pianoforte Se amate la
musica pile di videocassette ad esempio
non l'armadio pieno e tanto altro Ecco
immaginate ehm fate mente locale
immaginate un po' tutti gli oggetti che
a cui siete affezionati
Adesso vi chiedo un'ulteriore sforzo
immaginate che
all'improvviso Speriamo il più tardi
possibile ve ne andrete all'altro mondo
Adesso so che il concetto di morte è un
po' particolare e non è facile da
digerire per nessuno però tutti noi
sappiamo che prima o poi questo accadrà
e che ce ne andremo soli senza poterci
portare dietro nulla quindi è una
domanda che che secondo me è importante
cosa succederà tutto quello che abbiamo
accumulato nella vita Chi ha figli potrà
chiaramente contare su di loro affinché
custodiscano questi oggetti e mantengano
viva la memoria ma non è necessariamente
detto che sarà così chi non ha figli
potrà lasciare tutto a un ente benefico
a comune o a un parente lontano ma
indipendentemente da questo cosa accadrà
effettivamente a questi oggetti verranno
venduti verranno gettati via
Ecco a questa domanda in realtà non è
che ci sia una risposta ce ne sono
numerose quella che a me interessa
questa sera analizzare è una sola
l'abbandono
l'abbandono perché
immaginate continuate a immaginare
Appunto siamo tutti morti No abbiamo
abbiamo le nostre case chiuse
abbandonate e sono passati dieci anni in
10 anni Chiaramente senza manutenzione
senza pulizia senza alcuna presenza ma
senza alcuna presenza umana le cose
cambiano le cose cambiano e iniziano a
comparire altre forme di vita iniziano a
comparire i ragni i tarli gli scorpioni
i piccioni che entrano dei buchi del
tetto che nel frattempo si è si marcito
i topolini che iniziano a rosicchiare
quello che magari è rimasto in dispensa
quindi ehm anche se non c'è più la
presenza umana succedono delle cose che
accompagnano questo posto verso
quindi una appunto è un momento di
transizione un momento di transizione
che va dal
dall'utilizzo nativo della struttura a
quella che poi sarà alla fine e alla
fine potrebbe essere una
riqualificazione o la maceria la rovina
Appunto allora voi adesso avrete
difficoltà ad avere questa immagine
Perché quando si toccano le cose cari È
sempre un po' fastidioso però poi vi
chiederete anche Ma te che ne sai di
queste cose e adesso gli rispondo anche
a questo io lo so perché ormai da più o
meno da tutta la vita ma in maniera
diciamo quasi maniacale negli ultimi
negli ultimi 15 anni ho visitato più o
meno 1.500 posti abbandonati sia in
Italia che all'estero e vi posso
garantire che almeno un quinto di tutti
questi luoghi in cui sono in cui sono
stato
rispondono all'immagine che vi ho appena
evocato ho visitato
vere e proprie capsule del tempo in cui
tutto sembra essersi fermato distante
preciso come se ogni persona fosse
fuggita all'improvviso lasciando
veramente tutto al suo interno
chiaramente oggetti preziosi denaro
questo genere di cose non le trovi
perché
c'è già passato qualcuno prima di noi di
solito però trovi quasi tutto il resto
quasi tutto il resto quindi tutto quello
che è stata la vita di quella persona o
di quella famiglia o delle varie
famiglie che si sono comunque alternate
all'interno dell'abitazione e diciamo
che questa modalità di indagine si
chiama urbex sull'esplorazione urbana
lubex in realtà è un fenomeno che è
cambiato moltissimo nel corso degli anni
io ricordo
15-20 anni fa eravamo più o meno 50
persone in tutta Italia ed era veramente
una passione di nicchia ultimamente
anche Grazie all'avvento dei social E
comunque sia alla massificazione è
diventato anche questo un fenomeno di
massa e conosco all'incirca tre quattro
Cinquecento esploratore Urbani ad
oggettivi molti di loro In realtà sono
semplici fotografi amanti della
decadenza dell'abbandono e qualora
gli si dovesse chiedere per qualunque
motivo cos'è per voi l'esplorazione
urbana lo risponderebbero ma fotografare
i posti abbandonati in realtà questo è
molto riduttivo è molto riduttivo perché
sebbene non ci sia una catalogazione di
questa di questo movimento così
chiamiamolo così e C'è un'unica regola
che tutti quanti ripetono come un mantra
che prendi solo foto Lascia solo
impronte che in realtà anche questo è
molto banale riduttivo perché si limita
semplicemente a dire Guarda noi non
siamo dei ladri però non non dà altri
elementi per comprendere Appunto questo
fenomeno che in realtà è estremamente
complesso quindi ehm Con l'avvento dei
social appunto è cambiato e oggi voi se
andate su Facebook ma anche su Instagram
su qualunque Social ma anche
semplicemente cliccando su Google
troverete ehm pagine profili di ogni
tipo di persone che frequentano questi
luoghi abbandonati e che pubblicano le
loro foto online
noterete anche con un po' di attenzione
che spesso molte di queste foto sono
anche simili Nel senso che riconoscete
un po' gli stessi posti e questo perché
la massificazione ha portato allo
svuotamento del significato quindi non
c'è più quella che è l'essenza
dell'esplorazione urbana Che è la
ricerca costante sul territorio Ma c'è
quello che avviene un po' un po' per
tutto Ovvero
la logica del fast food Candy consuma
Candy consuma e quindi ti ritrovi
persone che semplicemente vogliono Quel
posto che hanno visto che te hai visto e
in cambio ti danno altre cose io ti do
quel palazzo e tu mi dai quella chiesa e
finisce lì quindi non c'è ricerca c'è
solamente collezione di luoghi un po'
come quando dai ragazzini si scambiavamo
le figurine dei calciatori Panini quindi
è diventato un po' questo e questo qui
in realtà non è neanche urbex ma ha un
c'è un altro termine che spiega bene
questo fenomeno che il Dark turismo il
dal turismo
si può tradurre come il turismo nero
turismo macabro e nasce in realtà con
l'apertura da parte del governo ucraino
quasi una decina d'anni fa della zona di
esclusione di Chernobyl e Questo ha
permesso di organizzare dei veri e
propri tour completamente legali questo
fino a prima della guerra chiaramente le
verifiche completamente legali
all'interno della zona di esclusione
della zona radioattiva Che tuttora
radioattiva quindi c'è anche quel
piccolo problema Lì però comunque a loro
va bene così quindi ci sono i tour
organizzati che ti portano a vedere le
rovine di questa di queste enormi città
che penso voi tutti sappiate che state
evacuata in pochissimi giorni a causa
dell'incidente della centrale nucleare
avvenuto nell'86 ed è sicuramente un
posto l'ho visitato più volte in varie
modalità sia legali che non e un posto
estremamente affascinante e estremamente
pegno di storia soprattutto per gli
amanti un po' della storia dell'ex
Unione Sovietica
ma torniamo un attimo indietro
al fatto che eravamo morti No che la
nostra casa abbandonata e sono passati
dieci anni facciamole passare altri 20
no adesso l'immagine cambia perché non
sono più 10 ma sono 30 e qual è Quale
potrebbe essere l'immagine un cumulo di
mattoni rovine macerie ed era piante che
hanno iniziato a prendere possesso della
struttura potrebbe essere quella come
potrebbe essere anche un recupero da
parte di qualcuno o una completa
demolizione in realtà una risposta a
questa domanda anche non c'è però non è
compito dell'esploratore Urbano
rispondere a questa domanda perché
l'esploratore Urbano in realtà deve
indagare il territorio e deve capire
quali sono gli elementi che lo portano a
fare questa ricerca molti di voi
ricorderanno anche film come le
avventure di Indiana Jones Goonies Io ho
un ragazzino quindi sicuramente sono dei
film che mi hanno segnato ma in quei
film ci sono delle componenti che
risuonano con l'esplorazione urbana e
non sono la semplice ricerca del tesoro
o il tuffo nell'ignoto in realtà gli
elementi sono il viaggio e l'avventura e
sono due elementi essenziali per chi si
occupa di questa pratica perché
fondamentalmente Noi amiamo anche
definirci un pochino come dei degli
archeologi
contemporanei anche anche di serie B
chiaramente perché non abbiamo studi di
quel genere alle spalle quindi
ed è per questo che abbiamo dato vita a
delle grandi comunità perché spesso
l'espressione urbana non si fa da soli
ma si fa in gruppi più o meno piccoli
più o meno organizzati la nostra
comunità si chiama chiaramente scusi
lasciti e attualmente è la comunità più
grande e anche più longeva in tutta
Europa e conta più o meno un centinaio
di collaboratori appunto sparsi ovunque
che indagano ognuno il proprio
territorio Quindi c'è il gruppo che si
occupa delle Marche il gruppo che si
occupa dell'Abruzzo il gruppo che si
occupa del Portogallo in via dicendo e
questo fa sì che l'esplorazione Urbana
avvenga seguendo quelle che sono le
regole appunto fondanti Ovvero la
scoperta delle zone d'ombra sul
territorio Ma
tutta questa voglia di ricerca in realtà
nasce anche da altri fattori adesso mi
ricordo quando ero ragazzino il mio
avevo 18 anni quindi più di 20 anni fa
il mio primo viaggio autogestito fu a
Danzica in Polonia perché Danzica Boh
non lo so avevamo deciso di andare a
Danzica con un mio caro amico e mi
ricordo che cercavo all'epoca
informazioni su Danzica e a parte la
Treccani di mio padre non è che abbia
trovato Chissà che oggi se voi decideste
di andare a Danzica
cosa fareste sentirsi il computer
mettereste Danzica su Google e in un
attimo sarete sommersi da video
fotografie itinerari turistici
interviste qualunque cosa che vi
mostreranno già tutto quello che poi Voi
dovrete andare a vedere quindi
Oppure quello che hanno visto gli altri
oppure quello che normalmente gli altri
vanno a vedere perché chiaramente anche
Danzica è sicuramente più di quello che
trovate online poi io ricordo che quando
ero ragazzino e andai in questa città
che nessuno conosceva una meta
assolutamente assurda soprattutto per un
ragazzo di 18 anni e ricordo che andando
lì facendo questa questa avventura mi
ricordo con questo pulmino c'era Era
stato un casino quindi il fatto di di
fare questa avventura e il fatto di
arrivare lì senza conoscere quasi nulla
mi ha permesso di godere della scoperta
di godere veramente di quello di di
quella novità in cui a cui mi ero
approcciato e forse è stato quello anche
il seme un po' di di questa di questa
mia passione e appunto oggi viviamo in
un'epoca dove tutte a portata di click e
gli spazi nascosti nel territorio di cui
i luoghi abbandonati sono chiaramente la
parte preponderante sono forse le uniche
Oasi di salvezza che ci permettono
ancora di avere la curiosità dell'ignoto
di provare quel brivido dell'avventura
dello sconosciuto e chiaramente ci sono
anche dei rischi da correre non è tutto
rose e fiori ma comunque il discorso
Però qual è il discorso è che
l'avventura e la ricerca in realtà si
legano anche ad un'altra cosa si legano
al fatto di cercare di non seguire
percorsi prestabiliti questo perché mi
piace pensare che l'urbex nasca un po'
da quello che era un movimento nato in
Francia negli anni intorno agli anni 50
del secolo scorso che era quello del
situazionismo in metabolismo prendendo
spunto dal Dadaismo prima dal
surrealismo poi aveva elaborato il
concetto della deriva la deriva
situazionista che era questa questo modo
giocoso di perdersi di camminare senza
nessun tipo di razionalità e senza
nessun tipo di scopo all'interno del
tessuto urbano ma non solo all'interno
del tessuto urbano anche attraverso le
campagne il tutto in maniera totalmente
casuale usando appunto come unica
bussola il caso Ecco questa è un'altra
componente fondamentale
dell'esplorazione urbana e che se voi
pensate anche ai percorsi che fate
quotidianamente
Pensateci un attimo No Cosa fate voi la
mattina vi svegliate andate dal punto al
Punto B Casa lavoro Poi non so Magari al
supermercato più o meno è sempre in
quello o in quei due o tre diversi Vai
dal parrucchiere probabilmente è sempre
lo stesso o avete ne avete due Vai vai a
scuola portare i figli però Avete dei
percorsi prestabiliti
e quei percorsi prestabiliti in realtà
vi ingabbiano perché vi impediscono
comunque di uscire fuori e di conoscere
e di meravigliarvi Diciamo che la parola
la parola corretta è meravigliarvi noi
quando facciamo esplorazione urbana
spesso ci vediamo prendiamo la macchina
e partiamo Io sono di Jesi partiamo da
Jesi Allora andiamo Decidiamo una
direzione a casa andiamo verso Ancona
andiamo verso i monti andiamo verso
Arcevia prendiamo e andiamo poi lì
agiamo in maniera completamente
irrazionale quindi ci facciamo
trasportare dall'istinto e anche un po'
dal dall'intuito dalla creatività c'è
una strada che non conosciamo c'è un
bivio andiamola e in questo modo questo
ci permette di conoscere appunto le zone
d'ombra del territorio Ma le zone
d'ombra del territorio non sono solo
unicamente i posti abbandonati
attenzione Io ricordo che qualche anno
fa eh capirai a piticchio picchio è un
bellissimo Borgo che è una un castello
di acciaio è una frazione di Arcevia eh
facendo ve lo consiglio assolutamente e
in questo Borgo cercando facendo un giro
per il borgo abbiamo scoperto che c'era
un piccolissimo museo del giocattolo
gestito da un da un signore anziano che
viveva lì ma un gioiellino Quindi anche
quella è l'esplorazione urbana quindi il
conoscere il territorio il conoscere
tutto quello che fuori dai tracciati
precostituiti
e poi un'altra componente fondamentale
in realtà è anche che un pochino è un è
un passo avanti rispetto alla deriva
situazionista E questa questa voglia e
questo amore per la rovina un amore per
la rovina che è stato teorizzato da
tantissimi filosofi studiosi da Young
Simmel Ma cos'è Franco Speroni che è
stato anche mio insegnante da che mia
Macerata e questo questo amore per la
rovina Non lo so pensate a Roma Roma È
chiaramente una bellissima città però la
sua diciamo che il suo punto di forza è
proprio la presenza di un numero
spropositato di rovine che in realtà
sono proprio quelle la calamita che poi
funziona anche per il turismo e la
rovina perché è interessante perché la
rovina ci mette di fronte a quella che è
La caducità e la finitezza dell'essere
umano quando di fronte al all'infinita
potenza della natura per certi versi
perché quando quando ti accorgi che la
struttura architettonica Quindi quelle
parti che sono state costrette a stare
insieme contro contro la loro volontà
naturale perché anche una costruzione
umana è una forzatura di elementi
naturali Quindi quando ti accorgi che
comunque sia la natura riprende sempre
possesso ritorna sempre comunque
protagonista Io penso che quello sia
l'istante in cui riesci anche a far pace
con il concetto di morte e quindi riesce
a capire che che siamo parte di un tutto
e quindi un po' come gli induisti il
braman per gli induisti quindi l'essere
parte di un tutto e un po' l'esploratore
Urbano chi consciamente chi meno
consciamente ricerca proprio quella cosa
nella rovina sebbene possa sembrare
contraddittorio perché la casa
abbandonata porta con sé anche quel
carico di malinconia legato comunque
agli oggetti che ti trovi di persone che
non ci sono più che magari hanno avuto
anche un finale di partita difficile
perché spesso così succede e queste
queste cose però il posto abbandonato
custode Quindi anche del delle spoglie
di qualcuno sempre un custode di
qualcosa di pesante però in realtà c'è
sempre quella quella sensazione quella
consapevolezza che ti porta a capire che
il posto abbandonato è un semplice
passaggio è un elemento in transizione
che passa da Appunto Lo scopo nativo
della struttura fino a quella che è la
sua la sua fine la sua fine quindi il
ritorno al primordiale alla natura che
accadrà chiaramente prima o poi a tutto
a tutti quindi
è rimasto un minuto vi do qualche
dettaglio tecnico quindi basta con la
filosofia Allora comunque l'esplorazione
urbana in soldoni è illegale quindi non
vi azzardate a farla e tranne che in
alcuni casi che adesso non vi sto a
specificare però fondamentalmente è una
pratica diciamo ai limiti
dell'illegalità quindi vi può creare
qualche piccolo problema con le forze
dell'ordine E oltretutto è molto
pericolosa perché le strutture
abbandonate sono strutture di cui noi
non sappiamo nulla quando te metti i
piedi all'interno di un edificio non sai
da quanto tempo è abbandonato non so se
ci sono problemi di stabilità non
conosci nulla Quindi ti devi muovere con
estrema circoscrizione ti devi muovere
tastando il pavimento per evitare che
Collie vi posso garantire che succede
spesso controllare il soffitto che non
cadano elementi appunto dal soffitto dal
tetto Quindi ti devi muovere in un certo
modo Devi anche essere vestito in
maniera adeguata deve avere scarpe
antinfortunistiche antiscivolo robuste
pantaloni robusti guanti perché comunque
ci possono essere chiodi sporgenti vetri
rotti vetri rotti Quindi è sicuramente
un'attività abbastanza rischiosa che non
mi consiglio sicuramente che non mi
sento di consigliarvi Però mi sento di
consigliarvi appunto di essere curiosi
di sì che se state andando in vacanza da
qualche parte ma anche se rimanete nella
vostra città e Provate a perdervi i
veicoli provate eh a evitare il percorso
museale nessuno Magari fatelo può datevi
un equivalente di tempo anche per andare
completamente a caso perché quello che
che ci manca veramente in questa società
piena di informazioni dove tutto è
veramente a portata di un cric è proprio
il poterci meravigliare
Vabbè ho finito ragazzi
[Applauso]